[Musica]
sottratto
no no scusate ma c'è un problema
secondo me questo palco è vuoto
e troppo vuoto
poi magari per alcuni di voi potrebbe
non essere un problema in fondo c'è il
bollino rosso la scritta tadic novara
uno schermo su cui poter proiettare
potremmo dire che c'è tutto
eppure per me questo palco vuoto
aggiungete che sono uno scenografo la
persona che di solito è proprio preposta
a trasformare questi luoghi
e qui il problema si complica
aggiungete inoltre che
soffra di horror vacui
locuzione latina complessa ma che
possiamo definire con terrore degli
spazi vuoti
e questo palco vuoto obiettivamente voto
è iniziato tutto così questo
problema
del vuoto fatto si calerà fin da bambino
un foglio bianco
era da riempire con disegni
miniature disegni per dettagliati
disegna disegni segna riempì tutto lo
spazio colore a fino al bordo qualsiasi
foglio che mi capitasse sotto mano da
una risma di carta la tovaglietta al
ristorante devo disegnare devo riempire
quegli spazi vuoti o peggio punti i
fogli non mi sono bastati
per fortuna ho scoperto che in giro
c'erano degli altre superfici
bidimensionali come i fogli ma molto
molto più grandi pareti intere di luoghi
abbandonati e quindi iniziato quei
graffiti
cercavo di riempire di colore spazi
degradati delle periferie delle tante
città
italiane i graffiti poi hanno cambiato
nome sono diventati street art e la cosa
è stata riconosciuta a livello mondiale
e questi spazi vuoti sono diventati
pareti di palazzi inter e anche lì
disegni colori riempire con contenuti
con la mia immaginazione per una
creatività questi spazi vuoti
sì che ha scoperto
che esistevano dei luoghi come questo
teatro come tanti altri teatri che
addirittura hanno spazi vuoti
tridimensionali dalla bidimensionalità
del foglio di carta a cui ero abituato
scolare c'erano gli spazi dove si poteva
ragionare anche sui volumi inoltre erano
predisposti proprio per essere
riempiti con
scenografie elementi di scena oggetti un
gioco bellissimo
e secondo me questo palco obiettivamente
vuoto ora potete capire meglio il mio
punto di vista è perché considero questo
spazio vuoto
il problema qual è
ora che per portare qua una scenografia
sarebbe voluto un camion bilic un tir un
elefante un carretto dei facchini mi ha
detto no ce l'hai
o allora magari potrei portare tutto in
bici autonomamente da solo e se e se
potessi
ok vabbè trovo il modo magari e se
riuscissi a portarle in bici vera per
realizzare una scenografia avrei avuto
bisogno di tutta una serie di materiali
complessi particolari legno ferro
pernici stirolo garza tutto si usa
materiali anche costosi si no
e se potessi realizzare tutto con molto
poco con materiali comuni magari con
quei famosi fogli di carta qui ero già
molto affezionato ai tempi
per realizzare una scenografia servono
macchinari complessi esperti persone
molto specializzate in ogni specifico
dello sviluppo di questo determinato
prodotto
si potesse realizzare tutto io in
autonomia magari con un oggetto semplice
come una forbice
mezzi
materiali
strumenti complessi
tutte cose che non avevo
avevo
una forbice
carta
e un sasso
no quella è un'altra storia
avevo una forbice
della carta è un sogno
il sogno di creare le mie scenografie
ha detto perché non ripartire
dall'inizio da
quel gioco che facevo da bambino legando
un foglio e iniziando a fare dei ritagli
apparentemente casuali ho capito dopo
che in realtà anche in un semplice
taglio fatto a caso su un foglio noi
stiamo esprimendo noi stessi
e la casualità di questi piccoli ritagli
che andava a fare in realtà
riusciva ad esprimere meglio
che a parole quello che volevo
comunicare
e quindi da un'operazione molto semplice
da un'operazione
che potrebbe fare anche un bambino con
questo non vuol dire che sia banale
sono arrivato
a quella che potremmo definire una
matrice
una base da cui ho sviluppato un'idea
questo
[Musica]
semplice ritaglio
mandato da ragionare proprio io che
temevo gli spazi vuoti
ho scoperto che che raderà proprio
creando dei vuoti in un banale foglio di
carta volevo creare qualcosa
interessante
e farmi aiutare dalla luce stessa a
definire il progetto
ora se questo lo posiziona bene sul
bollino rosso magari nel centro
no non funziona
era una buona idea ma non bastava
però un'operazione semplice può essere
replicata
magari cambiando qualche piccolo
dettaglio
ad esempio la scala pensato cosa succede
se questa stessa operazione la prova a
portare in scala più grande
e potrei spiegarvi tutto il processo di
ricerca e sviluppo e dell'occupazione
mentale cama portava ma in realtà
preferisco mostrarvelo e scusate per un
attimo le spalle ma ho preparato una
cosa che ora vi va da mostrare
come vi dicevo
si può cambiare la scala e la stessa
operazione farla in scala più grande e
ora se la magia del teatro mi assist
se la magia del teatro mi assiste
questo tecnicamente si chiama stangone è
calato da quella che tecnicamente si
chiama graticcia ed è il motivo per cui
amo i fiati
sono predisposti per farmi giocare a
questo gioco bellissimo musica ma la
scenografia
un albero di carta
è un po il mio stile peculiare quello
degli alberi mi piace questo loop che
dagli alberi ci facciamo la carta mi
piaceva usare un po di carta e farla
ritornare un albero era una sorta di
istituzione
capisco quindi che con pochissimo
materiale
posso disegnare quello che voglio e
riempire dei luoghi e magari da un
singolo albero aggiungerne altri quella
stessa semplice operazione
magari più intagliate
e ancora magari anche altri
fantastica la magia del caso
ora quindi ho voluti portare solo tre la
serie minima avrei potuto riempire tutto
il teatro ma poi forse era un po
complicato per gli altri speaker fare il
loro spicca come se fossero all'interno
è una giungla di carta però è capitato
di riuscire ad allestire enormi spazi
con pochissimo materiale e trasportare
tutto gli autonomamente anche davvero in
bici in treno con ben come fosse un
bagaglio a mano in aereo
e riuscire a girare il mondo con le mie
storie di carta
contaminarle con opere
di altri artisti
fare all'esterno farle dialogare con il
vento con il territorio quelle persone
che abitano i luoghi
citare la storia dell'arte che tanto amo
stare all'interno di quei luoghi e far
entrare le persone stesse all'interno di
quei mondi di carta
giocare con la luce quelle ombre
scoprire cose che quest'operazione
mi raccontavano le loro stesse che io
stesso non avevo pensato nel momento che
andavo a crearle hanno trovato una
soluzione al problema di creare le mie
personali scenografia e da questa
soluzione
era comparsa una strada
una strada che abbia mai portato
ad avere esperienze bellissime fare
quello che faccio tutt'ora cioè uno dei
giochi più belli del mondo
ma
per andare a chiudere
quella che quelli bravi delta richiamano
la chiamata all'azione dove voglio
arrivare non sto dicendo che adesso
quando poi andate a casa
vi chiedo di mettervi a ritagliare le
tende del salotto cioè poi se vi ha
fatto venir voglia di ritagliare e
volete tornare a casa e ritagliare mi fa
piacere ma datemi anche le foto
ma in un senso più ampio e trasversale
potremmo dire metaforico
nella vita di tutti ci sono problemi
problemi grossi che servirà bone tir per
trasportarli problemi complessi che
servirebbero una serie di esperti per
risolverli
problemi
che ci hanno detto che serve y per
risolverli
e magari ci rendiamo conto che non
abbiamo le risorse per
affrontarli così come sembra che va
fatto
ma quei problemi quei nostri personali
problemi sono anche dei confini delle
direttrici che definiscono un preciso
spazio vuoto e quelle vostro perché
definito dai vostri problemi quindi
quella cornice quello spazio vuoto è il
vostro personalissimo spazio vuoto è
proprio lì che illuminandolo forse
potete
trovare una soluzione e quella soluzione
sarà la vostra unica e preziosissima
soluzione personale
grazie